on nous a dit qu'il n'y avait aucun
remède contre le coc u19 et que la seule
arme pour lutter contre ce virus c'était
le vaccin eh bien ce n'est peut-être pas
tout à fait vrai plusieurs pays dont la
france et l'allemagne expérimente un
tout nouveau traitement à base
d'anticorps monoclonaux il s'agit d'un
anticorps fabriqué en laboratoire pour
lutter contre une maladie
ils ont par exemple déjà été utilisée
contre le cancer du sein du côlon ou des
tumeurs de la gorge
plutôt que de susciter la création de
ces anticorps par le corps lui-même
comme c'est le cas avec les vaccins
il s'agit ici de fournir aux corps du
patient des anticorps spécifiques
c'est le premier médicament réellement
efficace spécifique du virus pour nous
aider dans l'arsenal contre le coc vie
de 19
ça fonctionne si on l'administrent tôt
sur des patients qui viennent d'être
contaminés et au plus tard dans les cinq
jours
on va l'utiliser chez des patients qui
ont des facteurs de risques d'être
hospitalisées de se retrouver en
réanimation par exemple des patients qui
ont des soins immuno supprimer qui ont
des traitement immuno suppresseurs ou
des sujets avec des comorbidités ou des
sujets très âgées c'est une vraie lueur
d'espoir une vraie lueur d'espoir il
n'en a pas fallu plus pour que la france
comme en cent mille doses de ce
traitement expérimental traitement au
coût assez élevé entre 1000 et 2000
euros la dose soit 100 à 200 millions
d'euros au total
c' est une très bonne nouvelle en tout
cas nous l'espérons c'est sur le plan
des traitements et des traitements très
innovant quelques 83 centres
hospitaliers ont déjà reçu des milliers
de ce traitement qui pourront commencer
à être administré avec prudence
initialement dans un cadre hospitalier
pour des patients âgés de 80 ans et plus
et qui ont des troubles de l'immunité
mais la france et c'est le premier pays
européen à l'avoir fait à commander des
dizaines de milliers de doses
d'anticorps monoclonaux d'une génération
supérieur qui arriveront en france d'ici
à la mi mars et qui nous permettront je
l'espère sincèrement d'amplifier ces
protocoles thérapeutiques et d'élargir
la cible des publics qui pourraient
bénéficier de ce traitement est
bonne nouvelle nous l'espérons un
traitement administré avec prudence je
l'espère sincèrement c'est qu'il n'a pas
l'air très serein le ministre de la
santé et pour cause l'efficacité de ce
médicament n'a pas été prouvée nous
avons globalement de premiers signes
encourageants avec certains anticorps
monoclonaux mais ils sont très limitées
et pour celui qui vient d'être acheté de
façon massive par le gouvernement il n'y
a vraiment aucune preuve à ce stade que
ce traitement fonctionne
le politique a pris le pas sur la
science les pouvoirs publics veulent
montrer qu'ils font quelque chose et ils
ont peur d'être pris au dépourvu masque
test vaccin ce ne serait pas la première
fois que l'exécutif serait prise au
dépourvu on a compris qu'il préfère
désormais miser sur un produit peut être
inefficace
plutôt que de se retrouver face à une
énième pénurie